[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
voici les nouvelles
la france on a vécu beaucoup
cependant elle voit venir celle ci sans
manquer à l'espérance car elle sait où
elle en est ce qu'elle vaut et ce
qu'elle veut en algérie
la france en tant que d'une manière ou
d'une autre
se termine les conditions actuelles
de l'engagement politique économique
financier administratif et militaire qui
la tient liées à ce pays
et qui s'il restait ce qu'il est
ne saurait être pour elle
une entreprise à eau mais à fonds perdus
alors que tant d'autres tâches
appelle ses efforts ailleurs
cependant
dès lors qu aurait cessé les combats et
les attentats
elle serait disposé à apporter sa
coopération un état algérien souverain
et indépendant
procédant du libre suffrages des
habitants
pour lui
que ses intérêts essentiels soient
garanties en échange de ce qu'elle
fournirait
actuellement
encore
c'est la solution qui lui paraît la
meilleure
part que l'association des communautés
algérienne il trouverait sans doute sa
chance
et parce qu'il pourrait en sortir des
rapports d'avenir c'est con
entre elle-même bun par
l'algérie et l'afrique du nord d'autre
part
le président des états unis du mexique
monsieur adolphe lopez matéos a ouvert à
mexico le congrès international de la
presse filmée manifestation
professionnelle mais qui a ouvert aux
congressistes une fenêtre sur cette
capitale qui dès 1950 dépassait et les
deux millions d'habitants où les femmes
aux larges pantalons traditionnelles
côtoient la statue de pasteur où la
pauvreté voisinent avec les banques
ultramoderne m'ont poussé à côté d
église du vieux style espagnol des
buildings futuristes comme la faculté
des sciences
le pittoresque
c'est le marché de toluca cité de plus
de 100000 habitants qu'il a offert avec
son indien qui tricotent pour tuer le
temps et ses poteries héritage des
lointains aztèque ce sont encore les
combats de coqs que les sociétés
protectrices des animaux ont banni
d'europe et dont le goût demeure
toujours aussi vivace dans tout le
mexique
[Musique]
sans oublier la plage à la mode acapulco
combien durera encore la grève de
decazeville depuis plus de 10 jours 15
cents mineurs font la grève dans leurs
puits chaque jour leur famille leur
envoie les provisions qui leur
permettront un jour de plus de vivres
sur les lieux de leur travail et les
jours passent
une fois par jour les mineurs du fonds
volontairement immobilisé à 300 mètres
sous terre remonte à la lumière le temps
de fumer quelques cigarettes
puisqu'on ne fume pas en dha d'embrasser
les enfants de prendre une douche et
puis il redescend de reprendre une
faction santerne santerne parce que le
problème touche à la fois la raison et
le sentiment c'est le drame de la
reconversion lemmings de decazeville ne
sont plus rentables mais les mineurs
habitués à leur mine de père en fils se
refuse à être recasés ils veulent que
continue cette exploitation déficitaire
et tous deux cases ville dans ces heures
de crise vie la vie de ceux qui restent
en bas rues vides commerçants militants
et dans chaque foyer à la table de midi
des chaises vides
[Musique]
à
et
la municipalité elle même a voulu
prendre parti derrière son air elle a
donné sa démission et il semble que onze
autres communes avoisinantes les suivis
dans son geste
au milieu de cette population
sensibiliser les gestes naissent des
manifestations s'ébauche les femmes de
mineurs un millier peut être se sont
rendus à rodez pour réclamer au préfet
la reprise de l'exploitation et le
problème dépasse de beaucoup le bout
sentimentale d'un métier traditionnel il
faut que le pays puisse vivre d'autre
chose si la mine n'est plus capable de
le faire vivre et c'est là le vrai
problème
le bruit facteur de choix
multiples effets
le bruit qui est la vie
notre campagne lorsqu'il part marc
touati a recadré
est un poison violent un moment donné
redoutable fléau dans les villes
modernes et même à la campagne
oui démesurée qui ne finit jamais
détruit notre organisme halpern aux
fonctions ruine notre histoire
bourdonnant vraiment invétéré il nous
est partout à chaque instant du et même
de la tour
les sons que nous aimons lorsqu'ils
viennent à propos deviennent
insupportables quand il faut les
entendre alors qu'on en veut tu as
la plupart des personnes qui sous l
usine
au bureau
la maison irrité intoxiqué malhab
souhaite que vivement des lois efficaces
des méthodes nouvelles viennent les
délivrer de son audi va car la ligue
française contre le bruit reçoit du
monde entier d à peine saisissant des
victimes d'horloge huit coups tous les
quarts d'heure
peur en plus les plaintes des enfants
implorant le silence le soir à la maison
et c'est encore les cloches une église
de consonnes 13140 coup toutes les 24
heures la preuve a été faite que les
plaignant du bruit ne sont pas des
maniaques le bruit les a touchés souvent
profondément en débordant l'oreille
après l'avoir les et il peut troubler la
vue le système nerveux et la respiration
dénaturer le sens accélérer les
battements du coeur atteindre les tissus
musculaires
nous n'oublierons jamais le préfet de
police qui libéra paris de l'enfer des
klaxons et il est bien dommage de devoir
constater que des gens insolent
renouvelle parfois leurs crises kotama
le plaisir de certains vendent leur
voiture lors de ce cycle est pétarader
bien fort bien d'autres condamnés par un
récent décret invitant ces personnes à
faire vérifier le bruit de leurs
machines
dans certaines usines les sons les plus
cruels qui dépassent parfois le seuil de
la douleur ont été muselés avec vos
coudes adresse il faudrait bien qu
ailleurs l'intention soit la même
d'écarter le danger partout où ils se
trouvent
l'urbanisme moderne à penser soleil air
espace verdure il faut casser splendeur
s'ajoute le silence déjà en s'élevant
les demeures enfuis les bruits de
l'extérieur un écran ils sont est
fournie par les arbres et si les
architectes et les entrepreneurs chaque
fois qu'ils construisent un immeuble et
tu dit avec soin le moyen le meilleur de
l'ain sonorisé us de matériaux à leur
disposition de laine de verre saint
gobain qui s'adapte à toutes les
solutions ou d'éléments pour eux comme
le caoutchouc gilgen enfin de plots en
feuilles mince s'appliquant sur cloisons
et planchers
ou bien de tissus molletonné le logis
tourmenté retrouvera le calme le monde
du travail le répit mérité
mais ce répit on le trouvera surtout si
chacun pensant à la paix des autres au
respect que l'on doit à ce qui nous
entoure
quand le re habitude de ne pas faire de
bruit
l'école n'est plus qu'à nous de londres
celle de sainte mère ilbo n'avais pas
ressenti depuis le blitz de 1941 en
présence du lord-maire le duc
d'edimbourg est venu ranimer le célèbre
carillon refondu et restaurer et avec
une autorité qui n'excluait pas la
délicatesse
les cloches de mairie le bo ont donc pu
annoncer leurs nouveaux comme elle le
fit naguère chaque n
à grenade ce sont les meilleurs crieur
d'espagne qui ont fait entendre leur
voix à l'occasion de la fin de l'année
et les femmes n'étaient pas les derniers
[Musique]
improvisé ou non ce sont certainement
les voeux les plus énergiques ont été
exprimées pour 1962
femme est
allée des lapines bail en
bas
et c'est un homme qui une fois n'est pas
coutume eu le dernier mot andrez lapèze
salaires hinault
comme chaque année enfin en angleterre
la berge des checkers a réuni les plus
énergiques sonneurs de trompes de chasse
aussi bien que de 30 de taux il faut du
temps pour se livrer à ce sport un
certain souffle et on en déduira qu'ils
en ont en angleterre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les traditions comme on voir est salie
une année chasse l'autre n'est selon des
rites établi
[Musique]